hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are chatting about all things
Apple event
more specifically the new iPhone X which
is not actually called iPhone X it's
called iPhone 10 here it is the iPhone
10 it was officially announced today and
I've got it again this is a white
version and there's also a space free
version and this thing is absolutely
[Music]
we're at the home screen here it is
it has such an awesome feel to it
this is the space gray I got a chance to
go to the Apple event this year and it
was by far one of the most incredible
experiences not only because it was my
first time ever going to an Apple
Keynote but it was held at the Steve
Jobs theater and this was the first time
that this theater has ever been used for
anything it's official the Steve Jobs
theater is directly behind me and this
is my first Apple event ever and to walk
in to the Steve Jobs theater up to the
doors and see Steve Wozniak standing
there was the coolest thing ever it was
also one of the first times the people
outside of Apple have seen Apple Park
have seen their new campus have seen
inside the new Apple Visitor Center
where there's a retail store I buy
something what if I could buy things
here can you buy things here well I did
a little bit of shopping
but a little bit oh yeah just a little
whatever Mac I'm getting a nice chai
latte
and they have this amazing augmented
reality feature they have a massive
table that weighs 11,000 pounds yes
11,000 and when you look at it with just
your normal basic eyes you don't really
see much of anything but when you use
their augmented reality app you can get
an inside look at the entire Apple part
it's also really interactive so you can
swipe up on this little side screen and
it'll show you morning tonight what it
looks like you can also take off the
roof which was quite a surprise aside
from that we are here to chat about the
new iPhone which is called the iPhone
Ted not the iPhone X
unfortunately the iPhone 10 is not gonna
be available right away pre-orders will
be starting on October 27th and they
will ship on November 3rd starting price
nine hundred and ninety nine dollars
worth it out of all of the rumors that I
have seen the number one thing is that I
am so glad that did not come true is
that blush copper gold color I was not a
fan of it and I really just had this
feeling there's one thing I know Apple
is not gonna make that color a reality
and thankfully it did not because the
iPhone 8 comes in this amazing beautiful
gold color so before we get too ahead of
ourselves there were three new phones
that were announced today number one the
iPhone X comes in two different color
variations there's a silver and a Space
Gray the sizing options for these is
only two and it was rumored that there
was gonna be a 512 gig but there's not
there's only a 64 and a 256 I've already
made my decision and I'm definitely a
hundred percent getting the silver I
think it's so beautiful and it kind of
reminds me of the original iPhone next
up is the iPhone 8 now technically this
would be the 7s if we were kind of
following in the footsteps of previous
namings of iPhones the size and form
factor of the eight is pretty much just
like the iPhone 7 and iPhone 7 plus the
biggest how many
friends of the new iPhone 8 is the new
color that they have and it is a
beautiful gold color rolls gold is one
of my favorite colors that's my favorite
type of jewelry to wear and in the past
they had a rose gold which was more of a
pink and then they had a gold which was
almost too gold it was more of a yellow
so this gold is the perfect marriage of
the two I mean it's just the perfect
gold color that I could ask for like if
I were to make this phone the color that
I wanted it to be it's this color
I've owned eight pre-orders will be
starting on September 15 and they will
start shipping on September 22nd so set
your alarms add it to your iCal prepare
yourself for pre-order day so this is
kind of cool you basically find your
spot on the table it's not real the
iPhone 10 it's in my hand I've got a
little bit of hands-on with it and the
craziest thing is the phone is much
smaller than a 7 plus but yet the screen
because it's a full OLED screen which
they are calling it a super Retina
display I love it every time they were
saying super retina in the keynote I was
just I would die no aren't super to me
is very very funny so followed by Retina
super right now it just had me what
actually laughing out loud I think a lot
of people who thought that the plus
phones were too big but the smaller
phones are too small this iPhone 10 is
the perfect marriage of those two
you're losing no screen real estate but
yet you have a much smaller phone the
display looks beyond incredible its edge
to edge which means there is no touch ID
so Justine how are we gonna use our
phones with no touch ID how are we gonna
unlock it how are we gonna do anything
how are we gonna return to home pretty
simple you can add a passcode of course
or you can use face ID you can use face
ID and passcode at the same time just
again
that was it you just unlocked it do it
again yeah let's yeah let's see it
[Music]
but if you're familiar with any type of
facial recognition software it's very
simple there's really not much you have
to do you just hold your phone up look
at it and when it recognizes you it
unlocks your phone face ID is enabled by
a true def camera it's super simple to
set up I watched this guy set it up in
just a few seconds it projects and
analyzes more than 30,000 invisible dots
to create a very precise depth map of
your face and I watched this happen in
person I watched this guy set it up and
then I watched him unlock his phone
immediately one of the biggest concerns
with face ID is what if somebody else
has my same face will I be able to use a
photo how does this all work
is it safe one of the things that they
really stressed in a keynote is whether
you get a haircut you wear glasses put a
hat on grow a beard for instance face ID
knows your face this is far more secure
than touch ID I've been using facial
recognition for a while on my samsung
galaxy s 8 and my Microsoft studio so
I'm pretty familiar with it but watching
this whole thing in action was really
cool so you basically just hold your
phone out looks good
oh shoot
sorry you need his face and then you can
swipe up to unlock your phone but my
biggest question when I saw this in
action was oh wait how do I access
control center they solved that by now
swiping down for control center which
will probably take a little bit of
getting used to but even in this short
little bit of hands-on time that I had
with it I got used to it really quick so
a face ID you'll be able to do all the
things that you did with touch ID you'll
be able to unlock your phone and you'll
be able to use Apple pay something that
I'm pretty excited about and I think
anybody who takes selfies will be
excited about you can now take portrait
photos using the front-facing camera
portrait mode allows you to take really
incredible photos that make it look like
it was taken by a professional the
blurred out background really adds to
that effect and there's something else
that they also announced it's a new
feature in portrait mode it's called
portrait lighting it's really kind of
crazy inside because photographers you
guys are gonna be out of a job now
because everyone's just gonna be doing
everything with their iPhones
I mean Instagram models this is taking
it all to a whole new level hashtag no
filter but hashtag portrait lighting
hashtag portrait mode hashtag is this my
face is this my body I'm not even sure
I've been in reality that's the new
reality so because of these cameras can
sense depth you're able to make changes
on the fly so here's an example of using
the stage light mono filter this is in
the new portrait lighting filters
there's natural light studio light
contour light stage light and this stage
light mono which pretty much turns the
whole background to a nice black and it
looks like it was shot in an actual
studio one of the other rumors that did
not come true was the fact that the
iPhone X would be us PC and this was
something that I was really looking
forward to I have so many USBC cords but
I also have so many lightning cables
it's fine I can wait a little bit longer
they also announced a wireless charging
which is something that I've been
looking forward to for quite a while
they also introduced this little guy
this is the air power so with this power
charging mat you can just lay your
devices down on it and they will charge
wirelessly it'll charge the new iPhone
the series 3 watch and the new air pods
I got a few tweets where people were
like well what if I want to charge my
phone and use it
same time well then you plug it in you
don't have to wirelessly charge they did
it not some other partners who were
going to be making other wireless
charging devices so stay tuned for those
I know they mentioned Belkin and my
favorite friends Mophie I look forward
to all the third-party things that come
out of this announcement because that's
always something that's so exciting to
see what people take away from the event
and then in return create something that
they think that we need for these
devices that are missing I mean like
look how frayed this is all three
devices charging at the same time so
here's a quick look at what is making
everything work right here we have the
infrared camera we have a flood
illuminator a proximity sensor an
ambient light sensor speaker microphone
seven megapixel camera and a dot
projector so with all of that built in
to the new front-facing camera this
gives us so many more possibilities
animated emojis obviously extremely
important just when you thought you've
seen it all you haven't so you can pick
your emoji and then you can hit record
in iMessage you can record your message
as it face tracks your face to the emoji
and then you can send as your friend I
mean honestly you guys better believe
I'm gonna be posting these all the time
another thing they announced is the new
Apple TV 4k HDR the 4k HDR is going to
give you such a clearer and brighter
image I loved seeing these side-by-side
comparison photos because you can really
see the difference between the 4k and
the 4k HDR the colors are brighter the
blacks are darker and it's just an
overall better image so the biggest
problem is the content there hasn't been
that much content available for 4k and
HDR quality so now a lot more platforms
are supporting it there's a bunch of
movies and shows on Netflix now that
support this and I'm Alan mentioned
Netflix because I've actually seen it
firsthand they also mentioned Hulu and
ESPN and other live streaming sports but
I can only speak to Netflix because I've
seen that firsthand on my lg wallpaper
TV one more thing in this video the
Apple watch Series 3 looks absolutely
amazing I'll be making a full video on
this guy here very shortly but the
biggest highlighting feature of the
Apple watch series 3 is that now
supports cellular so you won't need your
phone at all you can leave the house and
you can stream all of your music text
messages make calls all without having
your iPhone I got a chance to check out
the new black ceramic which looks really
beautiful I'm probably gonna go with the
white ceramic again
so that's just sort of a quick overview
of the event and some things that I saw
today I would love to hear what you guys
think of everything did you watch the
event are you going to watch it
judging by some of the things that you
might have seen in my video today or
what you've read online or during the
keynote let me know in the comments
below what you guys think are you going
to get one are you going to wait why why
not what phone do you have right now
tell me all of the things and I look
forward to chatting with you guys in the
comments I also have some more iPhone
videos coming out very very shortly I
just haven't had time to edit so stay
tuned I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
[Applause]